actress Felicity Huffman is scheduled to
be sentenced later today in the massive
College Admission scandal
she's already pleaded guilty to fraud
charges back in May prosecutors want her
to spend 30 days in prison for paying to
have the answers on her daughter's SATs
corrected Carter Evans is outside the
federal courthouse in Boston with more
on this story so Carter what exactly are
her lawyers asking for well Felicity
lufton's lawyer doesn't think she should
have to spend any time in prison because
he's arguing this is essentially a
victimless crime there's no proof that
anyone lost any money in this scheme so
he's asking for probation a twenty
thousand dollar fine and community
service but today it's all up to a judge
the Emmy award-winning actress pleaded
guilty in May to fraud charges she
admitted she paid fifteen thousand
dollars to a Proctor to have her
daughter's answers on her SAT exam
corrected in a letter ahead of her
sentencing Huffman said she felt shame
for what she did admitting she had
broken the law deceived the educational
community and betrayed her daughter to
somebody Huffman's Desperate Housewives
co-star Eva Longoria is among those who
come to her defense in a character
letter to the judge will sentence
Huffman Longoria said her friend has a
kind heart at work on the show she said
Huffman stood up for her when she was
bullied by another co-worker and she
would not have survived without her
friendship today is the day of reckoning
for Felicity Huffman CBS News legal
analyst Rickey Clements says she doesn't
think Felicity Huffman will serve jail
time but that doesn't mean the other
defendants including full house star
Laurie Laughlin should breathe a sigh of
relief Felicity Huffman is definitely
the floor she is the bottom because she
has done everything right
even if Felicity Huffman gets probation
I don't think Laurie Lachlan should
think that the same facts applied to her
now Laurie Lachlan pleaded not guilty to
paying half a million dollars to get her
two daughters into USC earlier this week
the office of probation recommended a
sentence of zero to six months for those
who pleaded guilty
we'll find out this afternoon sentencing
is right here later today Anthony this
we will Carter thank you